37 seconds of logos followed by 20
seconds of slowly reading a growth chart
this movie has no right to take up 2
hours and 20 minutes of your life so
it's signaling early that it couldn't
give a flying around house to the face
about your time just get used to it so
he lost his first tooth on December 11th
2002 but somehow grew a full goddamn
image in the three weeks prior to
January 1st 2003 I know kids especially
boys grow fast but not that fast
oh Jesus here's 2.5 inches of growth
between April Oh three in May oh three
and my point is this movie thinks male
human boys grow roughly a centimeter an
hour and that is whack Jesus Christ
movie have you handed much literally
sixty two seconds into the film and
you're doing this daddy died
heartstrings bull also what kind of
parent makes their kids stand for a
measurement to commemorate the death of
their father sorry honey I know it's
been a rough day look you know the house
rules now go stand against the door so
we can submit in your growing psyche
your father's tragic demise unless you
think it was Trey himself who wrote this
in which case here's another sin for
thinking a grieving child doing this
makes any more sense okay what's worse
that he didn't post anything since daddy
died but now suddenly posts moving to
China the fact that I treated his growth
wall like a Twitter feed by calling
these posts or the fact that he wrote
this in pencil or that he capitalized
move but not China that's the back story
here did that board once belong to Dre
but this rain-soaked buddy wanted off
him on a technicality after betting on
something stupid like whether or not the
word China is supposed to be capitalized
and then the board became a point of
contention between them from that day on
Jaden their friendship until this day
when the friend realized his friendship
was more important than any old
skateboard so he decided to make a grand
gesture of platonic love by gifting the
board back to Dre cuz I'd rather watch
that movie than a Karate Kid remake also
that board is impact or anything so
unless he carries it on the plane with
him which I think they would stop him
from doing that board is getting broke
in half at 15,000 feet when the luggage
shifts god damn this is some Bucky Steve
Rogers levels brands and now we know why
he's moving to China because they funded
this movie dude from Detroit Detroit is
not a real place also I actually speak
the same language you do cliche
a John Mayer song about honesty and
deception and relationships it's the
perfect song for this scene because that
has no bearing on anything going on or
our characters also couldn't you have
opened here song movie title and credits
obviously not Chinese mother and son
flying to obviously China do we need the
last five minutes for any story reason
Oh bubble wrap his skateboard and that
somehow kept it from breaking United
breaks guitars but air china treats
skateboards like priceless heirlooms and
that's the story of how Adeline Packer
ended up stranded at the airport
wondering why her ride never showed she
was then forced to turn to a life of
servitude at late-night mahjong
tournaments turning tiles for enough
money to scrape by in a hellhole she
would never escape poor Adeline Packer
there's no nap but doesn't like show
depth but to some know depth is my knoll
[Music]
she gets out of the car what I'm
guessing is her new home I can't help
but point out that we've heard nearly
three-fourths of this freaking John
Mayer song in its entirety for the new
dude in 305 I'm Harry convenient aid
similar American is convenient look at
you making friends already with the kid
that speaks English and it's clearly
American good for you son you're really
starting to embrace this whole moved I
trying to think what kids I'm trying to
really need there Robert the sponsor
where's the quadrilateral trousers both
dubbed and subtitle hilarious kids speak
but I actually have set up lag we're ten
minutes into this Karate Kid movie and
I've gotten tons of kid and not even one
fucking whiff of karate school tonight
you moved to China for your new job but
you did it literally the day before
school starts there haha because you
expected the one thing but we gave you
the other thing hahaha
also I get that this is a joke because
the original Miyagi was trying to catch
a fly with chopsticks but if harm was
planted to swamp this fly why was he
chopped sticking at it to begin with
Jaidyn is trying to channel his dad so
hardcore here that i feel like by the
end of this movie we could solve the
whole nature versus nurture debate with
the comparative analysis of the two in
china public ping-pong tables use rocks
instead of nets because honestly I can't
even make up a reason why this would be
necessary or preferable or even exist is
this meant to illustrate poverty
ingenuity is it really easier to last
cast
a bunch of rocks over here to build a
wall than it is to find a few pieces of
string and paper he is sin I wish the
movie would quit trying to make me think
he is go talk to her scared I'm not
scared it's hard enough to get great
performances out of kids without getting
them dialogue that feels like it was
bought off the dollar menu at Taco Bell
to them all time their tape even this
kid knows who Bach is goddamnit in
movies all devices are at the ready to
immediately play the exact song you were
thinking in your head even if it's 2010
his spine survives this you got beat
twice now give up and go home
this is the kind of tin cup stubbornness
you only find in movies so this is
supposed to be like the beach fight in
the original then alright and I'm
supposed to be enjoying myself because
it reminds me of a movie I loved cool
just making sure remember how nostalgia
works since Hollywood gives me so few
opportunities to have it forced down my
throat
why no movies always turn the bullying
up to 11 is it possible we have a whole
generation of bullies who don't even
realize they're bullies because they've
never gone so far as to knock someone's
tray of hot noodles into their face
first she sends off Dre without lunch
instead of the fucking bully then the
bully is allowed to shoulder thump him
in full view of God and everyone and the
teacher does nothing public schools suck
everywhere
you're rushing it we have to work this
weekend so we can add the overworked
child perfection this kid to the
already-existing fish-out-of-water kit
and the over-the-top rebel bully kid if
this movie has a popular and stuck-up
jacket and a dark and brooding outcast
kid
I'm calling Breakfast Club bingo I never
realized how tiny China was but he keeps
running into these guys everywhere are
they cloned oh shut up and this movie is
a lot more beat for beat the original
film than I was expecting
creativity does not exist in this dojo
does it no sensei
tell that to your movie's title bub
[Music]
how's the peeping Jackie
it took all of 20 seconds for these kids
to go all hard day's night on the
Forbidden City kids while I can
certainly appreciate Dre's desire to
continue reppin Motown sports franchises
by the looks of the rest of his class
shouldn't he be in a uniform today I'm
surprised he's not wearing a circular
shower costume well getting even with
these bullies ha is going full jacket
Chan on these kids and for a few brief
seconds in this movie I actually want to
be watching this stranger danger much I
know Han just saved the day and all but
Dre getting shirtless and lying down
well hon let's some sort of fire suction
healing seems like something they might
have wanted to run past mamataji first
that's not how fire works now cue the
people sending me links to some weirdo
science youtuber putting chemically
engineered lemon sauce on his hands and
achieving a similar effect and I do not
care this is not healing you see when
you leave the ice so you easy to fool
what's the word for when Jackie Chan is
way more charming than Pat Morita in
reality but somehow less charming the
marina in a Karate Kid movie Chandon
Freud deja Morita no sorry guy says he
won't do a thing even though everyone
knows he's gonna do the thing and
honestly this is one of the most
annoying ways movies build fake tension
meeting yo you got a tongue job you know
peace on earth do you sex poster why
would this idea satiate Chinese creases
bloodlust here at first I wanted to see
you or your student get checked up
before you leave
but now that you've mentioned a publicly
regulated tournament in a distant future
everything's totally cool oh yeah I'm a
skateboard I almost forgot about that
thing that was super important for a hot
minute back in the beginning super
racist also isn't it kind of weird that
they're practicing kung-fu in this movie
and not karate I guess kung-fu kid
doesn't quite have the ring or nostalgic
name recognition of Karate Kid so I
guess I'll go back to my petition to fix
the pursuit of happiness Marty McFly
call he's wondering if the audience is
supposed to be impressed by this and he
told me more of this uncle remain please
no seriously I'd rather watch a movie
about crazy anvil REME then sit through
the rest of this beat for beat remake of
a movie I already know by heart why
Miyagi and Han share an annoying Creek
they both think that they have to lie to
the kid to train them like by not saying
doing these motions over and over will
help you learn come foo Han is I guess
just come with direct what'd you learn
and then we cut to him back at Hans
doing the jacket again if he truly
thinks he's learning nothing why does he
keep going back how much strain on at
least constantly asking why he continues
to hang up the same jacket
heyis work are you sure every single
shot needs a fancy establishing movement
of course nobody paid for a crane on
that agent Cody Banks movie I did so you
better believe I'm gonna use it here
we're both kind of practicing you know
skip shouldn't you be wearing a mask I
can literally see the dust flying off
that car door into your mouth mr. Hall
would you like to go with us no thank
you
too many people mr. Han I'm not taking
no for an answer I'm with Hans de solo
here how dare you force him to go
somewhere he's not comfortable the man
said no leave us introverts alone
literally imagine so she cats a lighter
we were in the sky not really narration
you're reading or even exposition but
it's just as boring and another complete
waste of our time so here's an extra 10
sins for the Chinese paper puppetry
shadows storytelling they are definitely
blocking the light here and there
pinky-swear should be visible to
everyone watching the shadow play
especially since the movies gonna have
them kiss each other and block the light
in a minute and the audience will see
that Judy's check it on so and another
moment ruined because we've seen this
exact wax on wax off realization before
except this time it's jacket on jacket
off which now that I say out loud I can
only assume was written by blink 182
stop hanging up these moves look nothing
like the moves he was doing when he
picked up or hung up his jacket not even
what condoms hang up their jacket with
their arms crossed I mean this one's
just a train shot did we really shut up
and order the helicopter now so you have
a license and a car trained please be
quiet
this isn't dialogue this is just b-roll
of the two actors between takes
she internal energy it moves inside us
flows through our body aka the force man
Lucas really did cripple a lot of Star
Wars from Asian cultures I'm like I'm
like a Jedi only the movie thinks it can
just reference Star Wars and try to
steal my joke making thunder but movie
was wrong because I got there first
in-your-face movie you you know I've
seen him carrying that skateboard in
about six scenes in this movie he's
ridden it in one the journey to the top
of the mountain
beautiful dragon well oh you got a
little Kung Fu Panda in my Karate Kid
remake looks like a few of these guys
lost focus on their waterfowl production
chief yo guy on the far right it's when
Guardium Leviosa god
there better be a been awesome water
slide from this mother movie thinks the
are we there yet joke still has some
legs left to it even after I ski you
beat the hell out of it and movie is
wrong
fun fact producers had to pay John
Claude 3.7 million dollars to use this
shot because he has this damn move
trademark this better be the tastiest
water of all time man because I feel
like you could have fully trained him in
all of kung fu with the effort you both
used climbing up this bitch let me guess
this Cobra sky move is yet another
paint-by-numbers replacement of the
crane kick from the original what's the
point of doing a new movie if you're
just swapping out pieces you drink and
nothing can defeat you this is exactly
what I say to myself every time I open
another bottle of wine also let's think
about what's required to have a
functioning fountain up here we are at
the very top of a hugely tall mountain
and that fountain is constantly bubbling
up from below against the laws of
physics
meaning the dragon fountain is powered
by electricity or some kind of motor
making it way more modern than its
reputation boom I just cancelled the
dragon fountain you're welcome Twitter
[Music]
do you have to teach this at the edge of
a high-rise roof though because I don't
think you do no one will be seated
during the Jackie Chan beats up a child
portion of the movie call me at cranky
geezer but not sure any twelve-year-old
needs to be this obsessed with muscles
or their power poses not sure any
twelve-year-old should even have apps
like that feels genetically enhanced and
wrong I know I'm wrong but it kind of
looks like her violin case has wheels
and I'm suddenly picturing a premium
rush style story detour where he
skateboards and she uses her violin case
as a skateboard and they roll around
town stopping evil flash mobs I'd give
good money at this violin case weren't
waterproof and later she got to her
audition and pulled out a soggy Oz
violin warped from water damage would be
hilarious comeuppance for this
ill-advised fountain John 10 Things I
Hate About Xiao Dre
[Music]
um is this appropriate somehow the most
prestigious music school ever gave her
the wrong audition date until literally
20 minutes away from the real date and
time it's the screenwriters fault
sure let's blame it on the school's
office manager playing flight of the
bumblebee at any musical audition is
like doing the Gettysburg Address at
your intro to public speaking class of
all the times to not be carrying your
skateboard his mom texts him that he
needs to get home asap which makes even
me anxious but instead he goes to Hans
house and thank God because Hahn is
suddenly drunk and destroying the car
he's long been restoring which leads to
you guessed it another scene straight
out of the original film it was a steep
hill awesome green car yes stop crying
and get to the tournament how did you
bribe enough studio execs to release a
two-hour 20 minute cut of this film that
alone is more magical than anything you
shot are we seriously doing another
training montage for three full minutes
this movie should have been over ten
minutes ago and we aren't even to the
tournament yet Jackie Chan is fine in
this film but mostly this movie makes me
wish for a Karate Kid remake with balls
starring Donnie Yen and someone that is
not Will Smith's son and his better at
acting in karate but mostly acting he's
doing the splits on a super high up
that's corner on a roof because of that
one scene from earlier but still and
again I believe this ability can be
equally impressively displayed at ground
level
Linda Lewis des Matta Hans take the
student into the arena before the fight
to be glorify the arena itself is
straight out of Hoosiers and I love it
still sending it for being all Hoosiers
oh wait so this giant tournament has
every match covered on a Jumbotron with
graphics points and instant replays even
in the first round or are they saying
that just Dre's match is being covered
either way it makes no sense
apologies in advance if I zone out here
the tournament part of this movie is
even more like the film it's rebooting
than any previous portion it moves by
the ref here but at some point wouldn't
this nonsense get you disqualified so
the firing cutting song gets ready to
dr. Dre with his flaming cups let me
remind you one last time that this would
never work ever and that's no diggity so
I know the movie is playing this like
it's a dirty moving on but he did just
get a point for it right so if it was
legal and what's the issue
Dre's the one who chose to come out here
with a bum knee seems like a very cut
and dried example oh don't hate the
player hate the game if you ask me
really every single one of these bad
apples just decided to do a complete
about-face
I haven't seen this much change of heart
since I interned with that cardiac
surgeon in the summer of 2007 also this
movie has 2 hours and 20 minutes long
Beverly Hills we always talked about
living there huh you're rushing it were
you rushing or were you dragging off
quite a lot in my experience there's no
such thing as luck Chyna mom everybody
knows thankful everybody was so the two
of them may be together for a single
night what is this some kind of
one-night stand
on the contrary Nancy I love you I've
always loved you
[Music]